today we're doing Cosmic queries topic
the edge of the Universe Chuck hey Neil
you gonna join me there I am but we
can't do it alone in that shirt
we have gen 11 to help us yeah
Barnard College Columbia University
welcome back I love being here we needed
you great for this topic because my
knowledge of cosmology is little and
yours is big and not not as big as the
universe itself okay all right
my first book is about whether or not
the universe is infinite or finite it's
a question we don't know the answer and
the title of that book How the Universe
Got Its Spots I remember that yeah so
how Universe guided spots is about could
we tell the shape and size of the
universe by looking in the hot and cold
spots in the Big Bang and the light left
over from The Big Bang but the question
is just take it really theoretically we
absolutely do not know that the universe
is infinite and uh it may well be that
it's finite the way the Earth is finite
that you know we leave New York City we
travel in a straight line as maybe we'd
have to swim a little get on a boat but
you travel in a straight line you're
going to come back to New York City
again and so it could be that we but you
can travel forever I was gonna say it's
infinite in what you can draw and where
you can travel infinite and you know you
don't get to an edge right you never get
to an edge which is beautiful so exactly
the same thing with the universe you're
not going to sail off the edge of the
Earth right like you know Spanish
explorers wave goodbye and wondered
right if they just go off the side but
no we know that's not what happens and
so similarly we could leave the Milky
Way galaxy we could watch it receive
behind us it could travel in a straight
line as possible and find ourselves
coming back to the Milky Way again you
know and it's it's so Planet of the Apes
right it's like damn yeah
you finally
done
[Music]
through my interpretation of that was
that they went all the way around yeah
and so the interesting thing is that
also means that if you look at distant
galaxies the light is also traveling all
the way around the universe so it could
be that some of those distant galaxies
are the Milky Way and we're seeing the
light from the Milky Way wrap all the
way around and come back to us we'd be
seeing the Milky Way in the past so it
would be hard to know like maybe we'd
see an active black hole Quasar with
jets flying out in the early phases of
the Milky Way and we'd think oh that's
just a different galaxy
[Music]
wow yeah so the galaxies the young
galaxies look very different from mature
galaxies right and we used to think that
they were different kinds of objects in
the outer Universe like quasars why are
they all distant how comes not a quasar
right next door with these monstrous
nuclear emissions and we had to like
figure out that it's likely just younger
galaxies and maybe we used to look like
a quasar and we don't anymore right so
even a distant Galaxy looking back at us
is seeing us in the past given the light
travel time so we could still look like
a quasar to a distant Galaxy like we're
I have this huge active Galactic nucleus
because they're not seeing us as we are
now
billions of years ago yeah oh my god
wow well and then it gets more because
there are reasons that people start to
suspect that there are extra spatial
dimensions and that they are not only
finite but really technically really
small like that journey to go all the
way around them is something that would
happen incredibly quickly and it's too
small for us to like literally stick our
hands in that direction in some sense so
we we're looking everywhere there's
extra dimensions are everywhere but we
can't actually notice them wow and so it
would be for a dimension to be smaller
than another dimension what's that mean
so think of like a straw is a good
example where it's a two-dimensional
surface so so a straw is small in One
Direction on the surface right if you
you think there's a direction in which
it's totally wrapped up and small and
then there's a long Direction so straws
are mostly long they're mostly long and
you could glue the top end to the bottom
of a straw to make that long direction
also finite so then you dip travel
around the world it could be really big
it could be you know mile around uh but
still be connected but it's only a few
millimeters around in this direction in
this other dimension so literally the
length of traveling before you come back
to where you started is smaller so most
of how you use a straw does not access
that other dimension it's really the
length because you're trying to get the
Liquid from here to here yeah so right
most of your you're using the long
Dimension yeah the straw so in we then
the question we start to ask is what if
the universe is a kind of space-time
origami when it's created in the Big
Bang that all the dimensions are wrapped
up and maybe in very complicated ways
like the dimension of the straw being
wrapped up but one dimension just gets
very very big or in our case three it's
very very big we have three big
Dimensions when we have time which is a
fourth so we we know there's up down
north south east west that's it you
specify those things and you definitely
know where you are in space you specify
time and we can actually meet here we
are but those extra directions just
maybe didn't ever expand and so one of
the things even that I'll work on and
string theorists will work on is why
would only three dimensions get large if
those other dimensions exist interesting
so it could be that we'll understand the
large connectedness finite nature of
space by looking in like really high
energy accelerator experiments because
people have asked at the Large Hadron
Collider could you perceive these extra
Dimensions if they exist wow that I got
to tell you okay Chris we're done with
the show
that was don't worry so here I will tell
you this is some some people argue that
the reason why the universe is
three-dimensional is because the
universe tries to be many different ways
there may have been an infinite number
of Big Bangs in the past in the future
can't really talk about it in temporal
relativeness but if the universe created
a two-dimensionally large Universe with
all the rest rolled up and small you
couldn't have organisms in that Universe
to ask the questions wow so you'd need
at least three and then let's say you
had four spatial dimensions then you
have the problem of things drift away
from each other in such a way that it's
hard to have organized systems so just
like Neil is describing a
two-dimensional creature isn't aware of
the third dimension but if they became
aware they could just kind of float away
from their City you have more volume of
space to fill the cross section for
interaction goes down so now if you add
another dimension the cross-section for
interaction goes down again sorry no but
we we successfully exist in three
dimensions in spite of the challenges
the two-dimensional creature would face
upon accessing a third dimension right
so why maybe three is optimal why don't
four-dimensional creatures pity us yeah
um right well that's that I mean that is
a good question could the complexity
like I'm just I'm not saying their true
arguments but some people argue that you
couldn't in the four dimensions get the
successful complexity and some of those
arguments are they get you know
complicated based on string theory
cross-sections and annihilations into
photons and what's left over after all
of these things in the Big Bang it turns
out that only a tiny tiny bit of stable
matter is left over already in three
dimensions so it could be wait a minute
let me kind of agree with what you just
said even though I just disagreed yeah
yeah what you're saying is in three
dimensions it could be optimal for
particles to get together and make
molecules and molecules to make
macroscopic objects if you add a fourth
dimension you're adding a degree of
freedom of where things can hang out and
possibly never then find each other yeah
ever again if you think about the volume
of the universe is going up radically
with the volume of Dimensions yes then
you're diluting everything in the
concentration of what could be but but
the fact that you're even asking that
question means you are a being in an
optimized Universe to even pose the
question in the first place so the
two-dimensional people couldn't ask this
question right because they couldn't be
two-dimensional people because the
structures are too simple to allow and
four-dimensional people there's too much
too much play Space so let's take it
let's take you your first question was
would we know it if the other dimensions
were large here's the hitch you would
say think we would but here's a hitch
even if all of those problems were
solvable there is an argument that we
could be glued to a kind of a membrane
which is a three-dimensional surface
floating in this higher dimensional
space
the way the fundamental forces work
between they keep us there they keep us
on the membrane and the only thing that
happily goes off the membrane is is
gravity itself right so that all other
forces are glued to this membrane that's
where they live so that you would think
like a particle to you interacting with
that membrane could be a string in the
higher dimensional space passing through
your space who's manifesting as a
particle manifesting as a particle so
like imagine cutting a string you would
it would look to you like a DOT right an
inflation strings
in two Dimensions I think of passing a a
hollow sphere through two Dimensions
what would that look like to the
two-dimensional people they'd see a DOT
they say oh that's cool right oh then it
becomes like a Circle and it gets bigger
and bigger and bigger then it maximizes
out at the diameter but they don't know
this and then it gets smaller then gets
a point and disappears and and they have
no idea
hypotheses come out and the scientists
analyze it we just say stuff pops in and
out of existence we don't know why yes
someone asked me when they take
Ayahuasca is it possible that they have
gone to a higher dimensional space okay
okay and my answer to an attempt to not
be totally dismissive was to say well if
it's a platonic form that we can learn
about by exploring the mind then in that
sense maybe right right like a perfect
circle doesn't exist in reality nor will
A Perfect Circle ever exist anywhere in
the universe but you can touch it in
your mind right right and it's an
experiment we can all perform so that in
that sense we go places unlocking
secrets of the lines of the physical
universe itself yes yes in other words
you high
so what do you say about Dark Matter
Dark Energy so okay so what's so let's
just start with the with the falling in
coming out and so there there were very
early on people who thought a black hole
could be bigger on the inside than the
outside it could be as big as an entire
universe on the inside it could actually
lead to a white hole which is basically
a big bank so you fall into the black
hole and you'll you know that is
completely confined by The Event Horizon
nothing ever comes out but inside it is
like something as big as an entire
universe so so that was an interesting
idea and a lot of people object to it
because it in some subtle way suggests
an unstableness to Big Bangs that might
make it so that this world couldn't be
stable if that were true but honestly
it's not completely off the table
there's a lot you could talk to some
very important early relativeists they
will still say that's what happens
relative is an expert on relatives on
relativity so then there's a separate
totally separate question about Dark
Matter there is a suggestion that the
black holes themselves could be dark
matter meaning that they are invisible
like dark matter is technically and they
could populate the universe almost
arguably large enough to explain this
missing Mass this missing matter it's on
the edge it's definitely Under Pressure
can I show you my black hole lunchbox oh
let's do it
I want to know what's inside the
lunchbox
if my hand goes in will it never come
out
exactly okay and inside of it is a black
hole Thomas but of course it is
confusing if you fall into a black hole
like this I guess you can't see your
hands confused oh yeah yeah you'll
disappear in front of yourself yeah okay
so you have a black hole thermos and it
is filled with okay so liquor
this is an inversion of the known
universe because in this particular case
inside your black hole I have the Milky
Way inside the black hole
a Milky Way out of a black hole
[Music]